welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to this episode will be covering
the first official trailer for Annabelle
comes home which just dropped in the
dead of night this is the first trailer
that I've ever seen that came out on a
Sunday and it definitely has a lot to
unpack from it so throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything that
you need to know about the movie this is
full spoilers ahead so if you don't want
to know anything about Annabelle comes
home and I highly recommend that you
turn off now without the way let's dive
into my trailer explain video and
breakdown the tease that we got ok so
straight away from the trailer the first
thing that you'll pick up is that this
is pretty much Anabella versus the
Warrens this movie takes place after all
of the conjuring films and is moving
away from the prequel aesthetic that the
franchise seems to have been leading
with for the past couple of releases the
film is due to release on June 28th and
it's going to be directed by Gary
Dormammu
well some people may be disappointed
that David F Samberg is not working on
the film door Berman was actually the
screenwriter for Annabelle creation and
then known as well as it and that's a
pretty good resume to go with for this
film the plot synopsis recently released
by New Line Cinema and Warner Brothers
reads determined to keep Annabelle from
wrecking more havoc demonologist ed and
Lorraine Warren bring the possessed doll
to the locked artifacts room in their
home placing her safely behind sacred
glass and enlisting a priest holy
blessing but an unholy night of horror
awaits as Annabelle awakens the evil
spirits in the room who all set their
sights on a new target the Warrens
ten-year-old daughter Judy and her baby
says it's pretty clear that the trailer
is going to ramp up the spirits with
Annabelle acting as a beacon for Kansas
ghosts it's a safe bet to say that the
movie will feature cameos from the other
spirits in the series so far and I can't
wait to see them back on the big screen
it also appears that the Warrens
daughter Judy too possesses psychic
abilities and this may be setting up
sequels down the line for when she takes
over the role as the main character the
trailer opens with them locking and
about away in the Museum of cursed
artifacts where we know from the other
films that the doll remain for the
majority of the series well it seems
like the doll will no longer be able to
horn you dreams the Warren
Storrs babysitter unwittingly enters the
room and releases it qu worst nightmares
I mean who goes into a room and touches
everything I mean come on as warning
signs everywhere
do not touch anyway whilst this is
unconfirmed completely it appears that
the movie will tie into the curse of La
Lorna which is due to be released on May
3rd that film introduces us to La Lorna
who is cursed to become a sparrow after
drowning her children the studio seems
to be keeping the connections pretty
closely guarded though as they will
likely try and pull her out as a
surprise in the film similar to how
split was connected to the unbreakable
universe but it's a safe bet to make
that you will appear in the movie at
some point though I guess we'll find out
On June 28th so what are your thoughts
on the trailer did you enjoy it and are
you looking forward to the film comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my full breakdown of
the scary stories to tell in the dog
trailer which would be linked at the end
this is the channel for people who were
mad into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best not see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]